so I first discovered your project for
tiny a story about living small while i
was on Kickstarter and tell us about how
you began the campaign I know you was
december two thousand eleven or so and
you started it or i think you started it
sort of late october and then ended
december fifteenth missed our last day
okay so what types of things were you
doing ahead of time to plan it because
you've done a beautiful job at at
getting awareness out about I mean so
many people just they make a video they
put it on Kickstarter and then they are
very passive about it and it seems like
you were both very proactive about it
what were your strategies either ahead
of time or while the campaign was in
motion well libretto chisholm because
she's the mastermind of the Kickstarter
campaign I mean I think one of the
really lucky things about our project is
that we had sort of the tiny house
community there you know ready to kind
of help us get the word out and in the
tiny house community you know there's a
really vibrant online community of so
many different blogs and Facebook pages
and things like that so I think you know
before we launched the Kickstarter
campaign we really tried to reach out to
two editors of blogs and you know create
personal relationships with people that
you know could help us get the word out
and so that was that was one of the ways
that we did that and then also reaching
out to you know anyone else that we
thought kind of had a stake in the
message that we're trying to get out
there so any kind of environmental blog
you know design blogs architecture blogs
you know any any other subject matter
that was touched by this story we
reached out to and we did a lot of you
know for film courage as well we did a
lot of kind of guest blogs and you know
making sure that we could provide great
photos and great content to kind of
offer to these people and say you know
this is the story that we have going on
use whatever you want you know and help
us kind of get the word out there and I
think that helped a lot we got you know
we ended up getting picked up by I think
for calm and you know mother nature
network and a few bigger blogs that
really helped us Sunday's channel blog
and the Kickstarter blog actually was
this group was huge so it's interesting
Kickstarter itself is a platform for
discovery and I mean I think you found
out about us through cases Kickstarter
but it just by putting on Kickstarter we
actually a whole new group of people
became aware of the project which was
really exciting but i would definitely i
guess about it like if i were to give
advice to a similar like and you know
another indie film that was trying to
raise money in kickstarter it would
definitely suggest that don't do it
don't do it right off the bat you know
wait a little while develop yeah you
know your plan and make some connections
and then also get a lot of the media to
accompany your campaign like where i was
saying with like great pictures and
videos and things like that because it
helps sell the story a lot more and and
plus if you you know show up basically
with some stuff that you can just can
show and point to and say you know we've
already you know done this or and you
know it it helps people with confidence
knowing that it's going to get made in
yeah yeah and i think to the message
with you know Kickstarter's it's not
necessarily so much you know asking for
money it's more about like look at this
great thing we're doing that you can be
a part of and I so I think it's really
kind of tapping into that inspiration
factor and as you know as much as people
can kind of do that I think it will be
successful what one last is that piece
of advice probably uh is too so one
thing that we did that maybe I would do
differently next time is just our
rewards you know it we didn't anticipate
how many people would be donating and so
some of our rewards took so much time or
energy to fulfill that you know a name
for for us it was okay because we were
still relatively small project in
campaign but first some of the larger
films out there then you know they can
find that they spend hours you know
fulfilling days fulfilling kickstarter
rewards you know so uh it's just
something to keep in mind for don't make
yours any yeah that's a great point and
i'm wondering too when things weren't
may be happening or maybe you didn't
have days like that but i know for our
campaign there were days where it was
just dead in the water and it's like
okay time's running out what did you do
to try to drum up noise about the
project i mean i think yeah whenever
there was sort of a lull it would be
like okay you know i remember before we
started the project or that the campaign
i wrote down a list of every single blog
or you know mailing list or newsletter
or personal contact I mean down to like
the colleges that we went to just like
the alumni networks I mean any any
community that I could think of to reach
out to and was kind of just cross him
off the list so if you know whenever we
had a low I was kind of like okay so
what new blog can i right or you know
it's helpful cuz my background is in
writing so it was easy for me to kind of
like figure out a new angle and write a
blog but um you know it was kind of just
like okay what else can I put out there
just to keep putting stuff out yeah I
think definitely the plan about you know
having a regular sort of schedule of
blogs so even if we knew that in advance
that there would be four or five blogs
that we're already willing to either
right or a disorder let us do a guest
blog we would you say okay what can we
do it this day because we didn't want to
have five come out in one day and then
have a week where there wasn't a so we
tried to pace it yeah and i think you
know it's important to remember too that
it's great just you know start small i
mean a lot of the press coverage that we
got you know started off being really
small kind of local blogs and
newsletters that you know someone would
see it and be like oh that's cool and
they write it about it for their thing
and I kind of got you know with the
reach became greater and greater but we
started pretty small and I think you
know it's not like you need to have a
contact of the new york times in order
to you know make a successful campaign
you
you can start with you now sure what
about four people though that may be
either aren't willing to write or aren't
a skilled rider such as yourself and a
lot of people approach us and I think
sometimes they're afraid because they
know people might read it and they don't
know if it'll come across correctly or
you know what would you say to someone
that it has that fear of writing we
don't so many people like that I mean I
didn't say that there's there's more
ways than just words to tell a story so
I mean if someone's really visual or you
know maybe someone could like do a
cartoon or I don't know I mean there's
so many different ways to get a message
across that doesn't have to necessarily
be in the written word I mean it could
be music or you know just really kind of
using creativity to think of different
methods I mean if they're filmmakers
presumably they do video blogs or
something like that um but I would also
say that I think any film is going to be
enhanced by having a good writer
attached to it so it's almost worth I
mean you know maybe they don't have
access to a writer at the moment but
that's kind of something that I'm
thinking about an advance is just like
okay well there's gonna be a lot of
things that need to be written you know
from a script to blogs to promotion
materials you know it's good to have at
least somebody you can rely on if you're
not comfortable doing that and if you're
under 200 backwards it was like what
9196 or something like that were they
people that you knew where they from
your college or with a family and
friends or were they i'd say maybe like
maybe twenty to thirty percent were
people that we knew you know either
friends who gave sort of like ten
dollars a piece or family members who
were able to give a little bit more but
i'd say i mean a good bulk of the people
who donated i think were either part of
the tiny house community or we're
excited for environmental reasons or it
kind of found us you know through one of
those blogs yeah I I mean I might even
be kind of a highest and it's her to say
but maybe twenty to thirty percent them
leave twenty percent of the money I
think might have been from people who
know because people we knew we had a few
large donations from
family or something like that but i
don't know i mean i think i was
surprised at how many people we didn't
know yeah you know understanding
strangers who were backing sort of
higher levels which i never expected you
know to have a stranger sort of back at
the five-hundred-dollar level or
something like that yeah really it was
really great and and from all over the
world australia lots of people from
Europe and yeah it was nice and you know
the interesting thing is when we first
launched a kickstarter campaign that was
we had 300 fans on facebook or something
like that and just as a gauge of we we
were relatively still new as a project
and and if we had even waited six months
from that point i think it it would have
been a different story you know as far
as we would have any more people we
didn't know you know because yeah it's
all about I mean amazing when you do
with you
you